hey guys I'm just McDonald you are tuned
in to my top five show and it is febri
14th so happy Valentine's Day to each
and every one of you let's talk video
games first up let's get the flappy bird
crap out of the way early there once was
a game called flappy bird and no one you
had existed and then one day everybody
knew it existed and enjoyed the first 10
to 15 seconds of maneuvering the little
pixel bird through Mario esque pipes
after this interval everybody realized
that crashing into said pipes was the
most infuriating thing they'd ever
experienced in their lives and some
people decided to take that blinding
rage out on the developer by a Twitter
death threat so developers since removed
the game despite allegedly making over
50k a day in the game to add revenue and
people are supposedly paying thousands
upon thousands for phones that have the
app installed on ebay the only people i
can see feasibly buying up those phones
are the girls on my super sweet 16 but
let me know if you've played the game
and what you thought of it next up
batman arkham origins has problems that
Warner Brothers Montreal won't be fixing
them a bunch of game breaking bugs are
seriously stopping up the play
experience for a number of gamers but
the death has said they're busy working
on the deal see at the moment so they've
got no plans to release a patch because
if there's one thing gamers love it's
buying DLC for a game that doesn't work
said game breaking bugs include
corrupted save files on 360 repeated
crashes and gamers getting locked out of
particular mission according to Warner
Brothers if they do release a patch
it'll only be to address that last
problem and not the others so basically
it's a glorified too bad next up games
may be making you morally deficient I'm
pretty sure they're not but a bunch of
Canadian researchers reckon they are
researchers from Brock University in
Ontario studied a whopping 100
18 and 14 year olds and found out the
kids who play violent video games have
less empathy for others and may lose
their sense of right and wrong non
violent games didn't produce the same
effect within the study which is only
correlational at this stage which means
a relationship can be suggested but not
proven so you guys think this one has
legs and what do you think 13 and 14
year olds should be playing leave me
your opinions it's the end of the week
which means some dev have a thought and
now we're arguing about it said thought
was from shadows of the damned director
mass moca Ronnie who said creators
should not have to justify gambling his
comments came in response to the
controversy over the short metal gear
ground zeroes campaign and can be summed
up in two granny believing that the fact
that the two our campaign needs to be
defended is one of the great failures of
our industry what legs d like your games
to be or does it depend on the game and
the price let me know last up it seems
that titanfall will not be running at
1080p on xbox one the beta which has
been released this week runs natively at
792 p and while respawn is said the
final build may feature a higher
resolution it's not been confirmed
respawn community manager our behalf has
said it could be closer to 900 p at
launch but it's looking like 1080p is
well out of the picture we haven't
received any info on what the frame rate
might be just yet were you guys hoping
for more out of titanfall and would have
been your first or second hand thoughts
of the beta you can let me know either
in the comments down below or on my
twitter where i'm at just look John
that's it from me for the week but I
hope you have lovely and safe evening
wherever you happen to be and i'll catch
you again on monday